à l'arrière de l'église orthodoxe de
butch à
l'innommable réalité
après des semaines de bombardements et
de combats en ville
depuis trois semaines des dizaines de
corps anonymes s'entassent dans cette
fosse commune
au moins 300 civils auraient péri à bout
de chats selon les autorités
venez voir venez les habitants parfois
enterré à la va vite dans les jardins
alexander est formel des hommes mais
aussi des femmes ont été abattues par
les russes douarnenez quatre personnes
ici j'en connais deux vocalistes oif et
comme on a pu face à annie de légende
les huit jours la menaçant il n'avait
rien fait de mal ces précaires et russes
ne comprenait pas qu'ils soient d'un
guéridon les appels leur famille au
téléphone il pensait qu'il livrait des
renseignements et au moindre prétexte
ils tiraient sur
des récits comme celui ci les habitants
de boudhha en ont tous aujourd'hui
l'armée leur offre un premier repas
chaud depuis la reprise de la ville
cet homme a les mains qui tremblent
il veut nous montrer la preuve que les
civils ont été tués sans raison son
voisin notamment
vidéo quand tu es au deuxième
soler contre nous ils nous disaient que
l'armée ukrainienne
il voulait savoir si on finissait
dans cette rue de boudhha les chars
russes ont même littéralement roulé sur
certains véhicules regarder celui ci il
est complètement écrasé quand on parle
avec les habitants il nous explique que
les soldats russes chercher à tout prix
à trouver les habitants qui avaient tant
lien de près ou de loin avec l'armée
ukrainienne pour les exécuter à bout de
chats mais aussi à irin le retrait des
soldats russes fait craindre la
découverte de nouvelles victimes civiles
à l'entrée de cette propriété les corps
d'un homme et d'une dame tué il ya
plusieurs jours
la maison de cette famille ukrainienne a
été saccagé et un message laissé sur le
mur de la cuisine comme une signature
voici ce qui est écrit
et comme une prostituée qui seront à
l'allemagne et aux américains aux
chromes dec gloire aux troupes
aéroportées russes est bon des jeunes
des soldats russes qui avant de fuir les
faubourgs de kiev ont laissé derrière
eux de nombreuses mines
[Applaudissements]